[Music]
now everyone of course knows the classic
monsters you got your Frankenstein your
Dracula The Mummy but what about the
other monsters that are equally scary
but not quite as famous right I thought
would give them the spotlight for a
change
and a piece for calling lesser-known
monsters yeah
[Applause]
first up first up this creature lurks at
the bottom of a lagoon that's attached
to a very exclusive Country Club it's
the creature from the white lagoon glub
glub glub glub glub glub tennis anyone
glub glub glub glub glub glub yes
this next Monster is Frankenstein's much
much younger second wife the trophy
Bride of Frankenstein
[Applause]
yes this next monster would be
terrifying if he didn't suffer from
memory loss it's the killer clown who
forgot his costume weapon and makeup
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and finally we all know dr. Frankenstein
built Frankenstein's monster but did you
know Frankenstein's monster built his
own monster and he didn't do a very good
job
it's Frankenstein's monsters monster
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
all right we got a great show tonight